one other thing i want to mention here
interesting story
it says a pastor in missouri rained down
a fiery sermon upon his flock one sunday
this month
scolding parishioners for failing to
follow god
the reverend carlton thunderbirk
condemned his congregation not because
they'd sinned too much or loved god too
little or done too few good deeds out in
the world instead thunderbird rebuked
the cheap sons and daughters of the
church of the of the well in kansas city
for not honoring him by buying him a
luxury watch
now i i'll play this clip for you i
watched this clip and i and i you know i
immediately thought okay
you always have to keep in mind context
and when you see a clip and it's 30
seconds or 50 seconds what happened
before and after that is there some kind
of context here that would make this
sound
not as horrible as it sounds well
apparently not because this this pastor
has since apologized for this clip ex
that you're about to watch right now um
here it is let's listen
see that's how i know you still poor
broke busted and disgusted because of
how you've been honoring me
i'm not worthy of mcdonald's money
i'm not worth your red lobster money
i ain't worth your saint john nick
y'all can't afford it know how
i am worth y'all louis vuitton
come on i ain't worth your product
i'm not worth yo gucci
[Music]
mother oh i'm saying this and i promise
you digging in is not with respect and
won't i'm saying it because i want you
to understand just what god is saying
even found out that mavado you can buy a
movado watch in sam's yes you can
yes and y'all know i asked for one last
year here it is the whole way in august
i still ain't got it y'all ain't saying
nothing let me kick down the door and
talk to my cheap sons and daughters
now uh
this is obviously wildly inappropriate
and actually insane
this is uh this is that's like
prosperity gospel on on steroids really
i mean this
prosperity gospel unfortunately
is uh very very popular
um
and
and even if the advocates of it rarely
will will you know identify themselves
as such but prosperity gospel is the
idea that uh
you deserve to be blessed
with with uh with
with actual riches like physical riches
um if you're a holy person that that god
will will will reward you
with physical
wealth and riches in this world
and that you deserve it
now of course that's pretty much
diametrically
opposed to what christ actually says in
the gospels
so which is why it's not the actual
gospel it's the prosperity gospel
that's kind of what we're hearing here
uh much more direct than what you're
used to hearing
that said you also see what a what a
what a advantage it is to have a
powerful preacher voice and cadence
because you could get up there
complaining that you're that you weren't
given a watch and people in the
congregation are saying hey men
that's right
[Music]
the power of of being a good public
speaker you can see what
you can see the advantages there
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're forming a cult then all you got
to do is click the subscribe button and
ring the bell below uh this video to
stay up to date with all my content and
if you want even more you can watch or
listen to my show at the dailywire.com
spotify or apple podcast looking forward
to welcoming you to the sweet baby gang